نعم طبعا فرق الانقاذ منذ صباح الامس بدات
العمل مع الكوادر التركيه في هذا الموقع
الذي نوجد فيه هناك فريق انقاذ اجنبي يوجد
في هذا المكان يعمل مع الفرق المحليه طبعا
يعني يتم توزيع فرق الانقاذ على حسب
احتياجات المناطق المتضرره اكثر المناطق
التي بحاجه الى هي فرق ان كانت محليه او
اجنبيه او حتى معدات والياتها التركيه
عفوا
ولايه كهرمان مرعش والتي كانت مركز
الزلزال لكنه هي وتحديدا مدينه انطاكيا في
ولايه هي اكثر المناطق المدمره والتي
بحاجه الى اضافه الى الكوادر الاليات
الثقيله للمساعده في ازاله الكتل
الخرسانيه الضخمه والات الحفر العملاقه كل
هذا الموضوع
مطلوب فيها تاي وفي كهرمان مرعش لذلك كما
تحدث اليوم التصريحات المسؤولين الاتراك
يوم امس كانوا يتحدث ان هذا اليوم سيتضح
كل شيء بالنسبه الى حجم الدمار الموجود في
هذه المناطق وامكانيه الوصول الى ناجين
كما نشاهد هناك اعداد كبيره من المواطنين
هنا تشاهد وتراقب هذا هذه عمليات الانقاذ
المستمره هناك سيده حاولت ان التقي بها
قبل قليل تقول ان اصدقائها او الصديقاتها
كانوا يقيمون في هذا البناء لكن كانت
منهاره بالفعل بشكل كامل والدموع يعني لم
تقب عنها منذ وصولها الى هذا الموقع وحتى
هذه اللحظه لكن بالعموم يعني ساعات
الانتظار طويله طويله ومؤلمه حقيقه احمد
يعني مشاهد لا يمكن وصفها ان كان هنا في
جنوب تركيا او حتى في شمال سوريا